[Música]
y llegamos al mundo como cuando hacemos
check-in en un completo y bonito hotel
con un cúmulo de expectativas y de
situaciones por vivir durante nuestra
permanencia en este lugar del universo
guiados por nuestros padres vamos
recorriendo poco a poco el camino
durante la niñez
luego la adolescencia y después alzamos
vuelo para enfrentar los compromisos de
la vida adulta
entonces transitamos por el colegio la
universidad el ambiente laboral nos
enamoramos viajamos experimentamos la
dicha de ser padres y de formar una
familia pero también el dolor la
tristeza de perder seres queridos
entonces vamos entendiendo que la vida
es una sumatoria de momentos si así como
cuando en física o ingeniería se hace el
análisis de una estructura unos momentos
son positivos otros son negativos unos a
favor y otros en contra
y en ese periodo de tiempo que dura
nuestra puesta en escena nuestra
permanencia en el terreno de juego así
como los preciosos minutos de los que un
futbolista dispone para demostrar sus
capacidades en un partido por momentos
nos asalta la pregunta bueno cuál será
mi misión en esta vida cuál será el
propósito de yo estar aquí y esa duda
esa que a veces llamamos crisis
existencial viene acompañada de una
necesidad de trascender de dejar huella
de no ser un dato más de las
estadísticas sino alguien que es capaz
de sobresalir un poco y diferenciarse
del resto de los mortales
es en ese momento cuando tenemos que
volver la mirada hacia nosotros mismos
porque el responsable de que eso pase no
tenemos justamente frente al espejo
revisemos qué fortalezas qué cualidades
que brazalete nos fue asignado en el
momento en que hicimos registro en este
mundo porque sin duda todos tenemos
dones y cosas positivas para aportar
hasta allí creo que no hay discusión
cierto porque todos tenemos cualidades
cosas que nos hacen especiales y nos
distinguen de los demás
entonces viene la pregunta bueno como lo
hago de qué manera puedo contribuir al
mundo haciendo uso de esos dones será
que cuesta mucho hacerlo será que hay
que invertir demasiado tiempo o dinero
pues allí viene lo de ser extraordinario
hacer cosas que la mayoría de la gente
no está dispuesta a hacer como es
recorrer esa millán temas
ah no yo eso no lo voy a hacer porque es
que eso no está en mi contrato ah no yo
no soy tonto eso no me toca a mí pero
entonces decimos ok no importa me tiene
sin cuidado lo que digan los demás voy a
hacerlo pero entonces viene otra
pregunta bueno a que me voy a enfrentar
como toda acción conlleva una reacción
tal como le no lo enuncia la tercera ley
de newton qué pasará después de que haga
eso extraordinario
será que se van a burlar de mí será que
me van a criticar me van a rechazar o me
van a mirar como raro
ser extraordinario no es hacer cosas
extravagantes o excentricidades o
locuras que llamen la atención o
pretendan impresionar no
es simplemente hacer uso de esos dones y
ponerlos al servicio de los demás ojo
con seguridad van a aparecer los
criticones estas personas que lo hacen
muy bien cuando se tratan de
descalificar
que nunca se equivocan porque jamás
emprenden o se arriesgan como ven nos
llenamos de miedos y motivos para no
empezar y hacer aquello que está en
nuestro ideal y que con seguridad
marcará diferencia cierto día del año
2009 siendo yo profesor aquí en la
ciudad de cali profesor de matemáticas y
física en un colegio en el día y una
universidad por la noche tomé la
decisión de abrir un canal en la
plataforma de youtube este canal lo
bauticé con el nombre de julio profe
para empezar a publicar allí algunos
ejercicios grabados en vídeo para apoyar
a mis estudiantes presenciales a
aquellos que me pedían que repitiera la
explicación o sobre todo para estos que
faltaban a clases por razones de salud o
compromisos de su trabajo
y esto yo lo hacía en la noche cuando ya
llegaba la medianoche una de la mañana
porque era el momento en que había
silencio total el vecindario dormía mi
familia también y tenía las condiciones
propicias para grabar pero la magia
ocurrió
cuando el poder de internet empezó a
esparcir este mensaje y empezaron a
llegar otros estudiantes a decirme que
estaban entendiendo que esto les estaba
ayudando y empezaron a pedirme más ya
eran explicaciones de cálculo de
trigonometría de física además de las de
álgebra y aritmética que yo empecé a
grabar para mis estudiantes
entendí que había una necesidad en la
gente un deseo por aprender por superar
sus dudas pero sobre todo por vencer el
temor hacia las matemáticas porque
históricamente sí que han sido un dolor
de cabeza para muchas personas entonces
hizo lo más difícil en cualquier
proyecto que es empezar dar ese primer
paso en la dirección que uno ha
visualizado como correcta y repito no
hice nada extraordinario en cuanto a la
forma de explicar no tuve que quitarme
la camisa y pintarme de colores la
cabeza o el poquísimo cabello que tengo
ni aparecer gritando o diciendo cosas
extravagantes no así como me ven
chaparro barrigón bueno en ese entonces
un tipo de 36 años hoy cuarentón y con
brillo incluido en la cabeza
simplemente eso que yo venía haciendo
desde los 17 años de edad que era
explicar temas de matemáticas y física
de manera organizada y detallada eso
mismo lo estaba plasmando ahora en un
formato audiovisual grabándome con esta
cámara si la que tenía hace 10 años y
desde el año 2013 con un teléfono
celular que se que aparece allí
entonces como ven nada extraordinario en
cuanto a los equipos
empezó a pasar como decía la magia la
gente empezó a llegar y esto empezó a
crecer
lamentablemente
mucha gente se cohíbe de hacer ese tipo
de cosas porque claro es más atractivo
trasnochar o sacrificar el descanso
viendo películas o telenovelas o series
o en plan de fiesta tomando unos tragos
con los amigos ah claro no estoy en
contra de entretenerse y divertirse eso
está bien hace falta a mí también me
gusta pero repito dar ese paso adicional
hacer ese esfuerzo constante y sons y
sostenido perdón que sin duda implica
hacer un esfuerzo pues con seguridad
vale la pena
al final
empezó a ocurrir toda esta digamos
transformación en mi vida y esto empezó
a funcionar y esto es lo bonito una vez
que tú empiezas y la apuestas a algo así
y ves que va dando resultados pues nada
te detiene ni siquiera los quebrantos de
salud como la parálisis facial que
padecía en el año 2014 o el bullying en
estos 10 años de aventuras en la red me
han dicho de todo cabeza de rodilla
tocan de piojos usted explica fatal
mejor dedíquese a cocinar en fin ha
pasado de todo
por eso como toda apuesta que uno hace
pues se puede ganar o se puede perder
hay gente a la que le gusta lo que uno
hace gente a la que no
y es allí cuando justamente toca
revestirse de una coraza protectora para
resistir los ataques no dejarse deprimir
ni abortar la misión y toca enfocarse en
esas personas que sí están aprovechando
y están apreciando ese aporte que les
estás haciendo que te están alentando
permanentemente de verdad es fantástica
la sensación de sentir que uno puede
transformar vidas con lo que sabe y es
capaz de hacer usando recursos tan
comunes tan corrientes hoy como un
teléfono celular y las redes sociales
y además poder animar e inspirar a otras
personas a que también empiecen a
compartir su saber su experiencia en el
tema de la educación a través de youtube
y los demás digamos recursos
tecnológicos que tenemos en el día de
hoy recuerden los criticones siempre van
a estar allí para hacer lo suyo desde la
comodidad de un teclado
y obedeciendo otra vez a la ley de
acción y reacción empezó a llegar la
recompensa el cariño de la gente el
aprecio de las personas sus muestras de
agradecimiento todo eso que al final lo
anima a uno a continuar y pues invitar
también a las personas a que nos compren
nos comportemos como ciudadanos de bien
solidarios con los demás y con el
planeta que habitamos para que durante
nuestra breve permanencia en el mismo
nos convirtamos porque no en leyendas
entonces vale la pena intentarlo dar ese
primer paso y avanzar para que cuando
hagamos check out de este mundo seamos
recordados por todo eso que fuimos
capaces de hacer en de los demás sin
egoísmo sin pereza sin pasar por encima
de nadie
brillando con luz propia sin opacar la
de los demás y porque si pudimos ser
extraordinarias